well you know who also dj's at the wynn
is our our friend of the show kim lee
who happened to appear on netflix's very
popular show bling empire where you
might also have seen our next guest so
threading has become a very common
process in the world of advanced
aesthetics so much so that you could
have seen the actual process on
netflix's bling empire and here to tell
us more about it is dr sai thanks for
being here hi thanks for having me on
the show julian and before we jump into
anything um you just celebrated a
birthday happy birthday just a few days
ago thank you thank you just turned the
big 50. oh my gosh congratulations and
hey keeping the celebrations going out
here in las vegas so first off let's
talk about what you're doing out here in
vegas so i'm here to speak and on behalf
of several thread companies regarding
the pdf thread lifts this is what you
may have seen on the show and uh so i'm
speaking at it's called the aesthetic
show it's the number one aesthetic show
across the country once a year wow in
our industry well okay let's jump right
into it because i remember watching oh
and there we have kane on the show from
bling empire i remember watching that
episode seeing this threading process
happening and just to my mind i'm
thinking
what is that so can you break it down
for us and explain the process sure so
thread lifting is using absorbable
sutures the same stitches that you use
to get sewed up after surgery and these
stitches absorb and dissolve so they're
placed underneath the skin giving a
non-surgical face lift and then kane's
instance actually threaded his nose so i
gave him a more augmented bridge and
lifted his tip wow yes i remember seeing
and the healing process and just seeing
you go in and lift it up and he was all
about it i think everyone's biggest
question does it hurt okay so the only
thing
that is a little uncomfortable is the
numbing so i have to know me so but once
you're numb it's completely painless and
what's the recovery process like how
quickly do you notice the difference and
how long is the healing well the results
are right away oh yeah the right away
but there's a little bit of swelling a
little bit of down time maybe like a
little bit of one week of socially
acceptable down time but after week i
mean some people go to work the next day
and especially with a mask you know yeah
that's true you can hide anything under
that
and this treatment was popular across
the world but now it's kind of making
its way into the state so is that fun
for you to get to to do things like this
that are a little bit out of the
ordinary but becoming mainstream now
right so this has been around for other
countries for like 10 20 years so it's
nothing really new but in the united
states i think it's getting more popular
in the last several years and it's still
rising i mean the demand for this is
just growing and growing and also glad
to be part of the community the training
providers making sure that they're doing
it safely and effectively for their
patients oh well that's all great to
know dr sai thank you so much for
breaking it down and again you know you
see things on tv and you're like what is
that like in real life so i'm happy to
to hear that it's not too painful cain
looked great you obviously know what
you're doing
enjoy your time in vegas continue those
birthday celebrations and come visit us
next time you're out for the convention
thanks for inviting me all right we will
see you after the break